bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors le colonel
simi goïta affirme être le président du
comité national pour le salut du pape
une instance donc installé par les
militaires ibrahim boubacar keïta le
président malien est toujours aux mains
de la junte
comment est-ce que vous interprétez
cette situation on est dans quoi
exactement est ce que c'est un
réellement un coup d'état une tentative
de coup d'état ou toujours une mutinerie
nous sommes dans le jour d'après c'est
vrai qu'à plusieurs termes qui viennent
s'inviter sont convoqués sont à
l'international ou soit sur le plan du
mali je vous propose de faire une
plongée sociologique et politique au
coeur même du mali plusieurs sentiments
au sein de la population se font jour
ce qui prédomine c'est le soulagement
c'est non l'encensement d'un coup d'état
ou mother de putschistes ou de muta les
militaires ne sont pas vus par la grande
partie des des maliens aujourd'hui comme
des putschistes ou comme des personnes
qui ont commis un coup d'état même sur
le plan sur le plan légal sur le plan
juridique il s'agit bien d'un coup
d'état il a été fait sans eux sans
résistance de la part du premier
ministre des ministres ce qu'on est
arrêté et notamment le premier d'entre
eux le président donc il ya ce qu est ce
qu on peut appeler un coup d'état
pacifique
on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui ce qui a été
dit cette nuit par les oppositions mais
aussi par les militaires c'est qu'un
rapprochement c'est à dire que les
militaires n'ont pas vocation à rester
au pouvoir
il parle depuis deux jours d'une
transition d'une transition civile et
politique
je rajouterais démocratique sûrement que
le mot démocratique va se coller à ces
deux mots on peut dire que il ya
plusieurs sentiments qui sont
entremêlées entre inquiétude
incertitudes soulagement le mali en
rendez vous avec lui m aussi bien toute
la société civile les individus
la classe politique les le champ
économique et le champ politique mais
mais quelle transition politique
possible puisqu'on voit bien que
l'opposition notamment les mouvements du
5 juin mais l'imam dicko gardent leurs
distances avec les militaires pour
l'instant oui c'est une distance tout à
fait logique
on a affaire à des militaires les
militaires on a vocation à rester dans
les casernes sont sortis de la brigade
de leur période prérogatives pour au
regard de la situation où la société
malienne et le peuple malien était dans
un état d'apnée et de sidération et de
saturation social et économique avec des
insécurités complètement généralisée il
considérait qu'il n'avait plus d'état
que l'état était exemple donc les
militaires ont pratiqué le ski le ski
est appelée de différentes façons coup
d'état beauty is mutinerie ou autre donc
il ya des diables il ya une main tendue
de la part des militaires à la société
civile et notamment aux mouvements au
mouvement m5 qui demain va fêter entre
guillemets cette victoire populaire
parce que c'est aussi vécue comme une
victoire populaire démocratique et
politique dont tout de suite après il y
aura une feuille de route qui n'est pas
fait par les militaires qui sera fait
par la société civile les syndicats la
classe politique les élites malienne le
champ économique et la communauté
internationale qui j'espère va mieux se
plonger sur le pont la sociologie et de
l'histoire du mali pour comprendre il
est vrai que d'une main la fermeté sur
le plan juridique est tout à fait
compréhensible et de l'autre d'appeler à
une négociation à des solutions
négociées démocratique et pacifique la
communauté internationale qui maintient
la pression on sait que la cedeao a
fermé ses frontières ça veut dire que il
ya un risque de pénurie en tout genre
dans ce pays pauvre du sahel
finalement est-ce que l'étau se resserre
autour à de la junte militaire
l'étau l'étau se resserre oui oui et non
parce que la cedeao
c'est vrai qu'elle condamne mais la
cedeao doit aussi pratiqué à une
introspection et énergie elle en manteau
de leur propre structure
il manque aussi de plus en plus de
crédibilité même si leur crédibilité
n'est pas discutée et discutable mais
elle est contestée sur le plan politique
et les mêmes la communauté
internationale c'est vrai qu'un renfort
de condamnation certes mais qu'en est il
quid de toute la gestion de prévention
des conflits de présence de prévention
des mauvaises gouvernances on va bien
que dans le sahel ou en afrique de
l'ouest ou ailleurs en afrique ou
ailleurs dans le monde
la prévention des conflits sur le plan
politique et sur le plan des mauvaises
gouvernances les sociétés entre
guillemets parce que la communauté
internationale
les maliens en font partie la communauté
internationale n'est que la somme des
populations du monde donc il faut
absolument que ne pas voir comme une
communauté internationale qui serait
tutélaire à l'égard de l'afrique ou du
peuple malien dont qu'ils entendent
vraiment l'ensemble de la société civile
et bien sûr les dirigeants ce qui
pourrait aider à la négociation c'est la
libération du président entre guillemets
sortant que contrat contrainte de
démissionner et d'avoir dissout
l'assemblée nationale c'est un geste
fort que d'affaires la junte où on peut
les appeler comme on veut mais il ya un
processus entre guillemets ou à
partenariat stratégique avec tous les
acteurs et au sein même du mali c'est
par là que ça va commencer de tous les
protagonistes soient maliens que toutes
les strates du mali et batterie puisse
prendre en compte et en main leur destin
si ce qu'ils font depuis toutes les
semaines ils manifestent c'est vrai que
le monde ne l'a peut-être pas assez
entendu ne l'a peut-être pas assez
perçue mais pour ceux qui vivent au mali
au quotidien les difficultés sociales
économiques sentait que quelque chose
que quelque chose allait quelque chose
de ceux de cet acabit aurait pu
pouvait se passer c'est vrai que la vie
malienne est jalonnée de ce type de coup
de semonce de coup d'état mais c'est la
première fois qu'un coup d'état est
accueilli en liesse avec des coups de
feu en l'air et pas sur la population
juste une question assez rapidement s'il
vous plaît jean claude léostic à lyon
c'était une présence militaire française
une présence militaire onusienne avec la
minus marre et on peut s'étonner quelque
part justement d'une absence d'
ingérence dans les derniers événements
que on a pu observer au mali on sait que
par exemple la france elle était
intervenue en 2008 au tchad pour
justement porté secours au président
tchadien idriss deby qui était sous le
coup aussi d'une insurrection mais
l'absence d' ingérence est tout à fait
compréhensible les observateurs
militaires et stratégiques ont compris
ce qui allait se passer ce qui s'est
déroulé et laisse la mare la société
civile laisse la main aux militaires et
notamment aux politiques ils restent à
leur place
les mutins entre les mutants tout cas
les militaires chez qui on qui ont fait
ce coup d'état ont tout de suite dit
qu'il ne rompait pas les contrats
stratégiques et militaires avec la
france avec l'onu donc les treize mille
militaires de la minus ma
c'est ce sont des hauts officiers les
plus au filet les officiers les plus les
plus dotés les plus chevronnés du mali
qui sont qui ont organisé donc ce coup
d'état tout leur profil est connue des
maliens c'est pour cela que les maliens
sont sortis la poitrine d'or et le
sourire aux lèvres parce qu'il savait
que ça allait être pacifique
donc il ya dans leurs discours qui est
très géopolitique stands ils ne
remettent pas en cause la présence de la
france ils ne remettent pas en cause la
présence de la coalition notamment avec
l'onu et d'autres armées étrangères pour
combattre l'hydre l'hydre terroriste qui
savent bien ils sont cités il vraiment
sont très bien placés étant donné le
côté chevronné est bien dotée en termes
de grade et connaissance du terrain que
pour combattre le terrorisme
que ça soit au sein du mali et dans tout
le sahel et dans le monde parce que
c'est une guerre asymétrique contre le
contre le terrorisme il faut que tout le
monde soit là dans un partenariat
stratégique et militaire
et pour lui merci à vous jean claude mas
félix tchicaya je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à alips off